good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the hallmark of any
authoritarian regime is politicized
justice under that system your opponents
go to jail your supporters can do
whatever they want and this reveals that
the state exists not to serve the people
who live in it but to preserve itself
and to crush all dissent
i hate to think we've reached a point
anywhere near that here in the united
states because there's nothing worse
than that or scary or harder to fix
but in fact we have reached that point
that's where we are yesterday for
example a man leaped on stage at a
campaign event and tried to stab lee
zeldin zeldin's as sitting member of
congress he's challenging the unelected
incumbent kathy hokel in the governor's
race in new york
so ordinarily attempting to assassinate
a federal office holder would be
considered a big deal
but lee zeldin is a republican so it's
not a big deal anymore the man who tried
to murder lee zeldin was released
immediately with no bail
less than 24 hours later by contrast
former trump adviser steve bannon was
convicted of crimes that until recently
were not crimes at all
for which he now faces a prison term of
two years
bannon has been declared guilty of
something called contempt of congress
that may strike you as an
unintentionally hilarious term since
most of the time congress invites our
contempt
but the point is this is a crime the
democrats are not convicted of ever
attorney general eric holder an irs
executive lois lerner were once found to
be in contempt of congress both of them
and for real crimes in holder's case it
was gun running in mexico in learner's
case it was targeting conservatives for
audits
but neither one went to trial holder
claimed executive privilege which was
enough even after a judge ruled that
executive privilege did not apply in
eric holder's case but it didn't matter
he walked
lois lerner cited the fifth amendment it
was as simple as that both of them today
lerner and holder are free and richer
than ever
but these standards do not apply to
steve bannon steve bannon was subpoenaed
by the january 6 committee despite the
fact he had literally nothing to do with
january 6th
we know that because he left the white
house three years before it happened but
it didn't matter he annoyed the wrong
people so he's going to jail
now this shouldn't surprise you really
because we've been building toward this
moment for some time you might recall
greg craig that would be barack obama's
former white house counsel
he was acquitted of violating the
foreign agents registration act farah
back in 2019 he'd been working for
ukraine
now at almost exactly the same moment
paul manafort who hired greg craig to
work on ukraine was convicted of
violating the same law farrah
on the same
account for ukraine
how does that work exactly it seems like
a double standard and indeed it is a
double standard but it's a consistent
standard we've seen it again and again
and again
former clinton attorney michael sussman
was just acquitted by a dc jury of lying
to the fbi that happened in may the
theory was that really who knows what
michael sussman told the fbi about
non-existent russian servers in trump
tower
okay
as long as we're using that theory does
it work for everyone well it didn't work
for george papadopoulos didn't work for
michael flynn on the other hand neither
one of those guys had a key card to fbi
headquarters like michael sussman did
and that came in handy that relationship
but mike flynn didn't have that
relationship his life was destroyed why
because of handwritten notes by peter
strzok who you can now see on msnbc but
their conversation in the white house
about russian sanctions
get him to lie
the head of counterintelligence the fbi
wrote to strzok speaking of flynn
so in the basis of that the setup
they hounded mike flynn into poverty
the same thing happened in george
papadopoulos papadopoulos crime not
being as forthcoming as possible about
his job status with the trump campaign
unpaid that's literally what the doj
told the court in a filing quote the
defendant did not provide substantial
assistance
oh that's the standard
so papadopoulos went to prison
so did the 69 year old grandmother
recently called pam hemphill she's
currently serving a two-month sentence
in federal prison why because she quote
paraded in the capitol on january 6.
didn't hurt anyone she's got breast
cancer she's going to prison
a judge in washington no problem issuing
that sentence at exactly the same moment
the u.s attorney for d.c dropped all
charges against stephen colbert's
production crew for doing the same thing
but worse
so stephen colbert's team may have lied
to federal authorities when they said
they'd stayed at restricted areas
but they didn't lie to federal
authorities in quite the same way
apparently
and of course they had the right
politics unlike roger stone
roger stone got a three-year prison
sentence he had a swat team show up at
his house at dawn with the cnn crew in
tow tipped off by the justice department
for maximum humiliation what was his
crime no one can remember because there
wasn't one
so if you've been paying any attention
at all to our justice system
particularly under merrick garland you
had some sense of where this was going
it was moving toward the authoritarian
system we now have where justice is an
illusion offend the people in charge get
punished
support the people in charge do whatever
you want
still even knowing that today's
conviction of steve bannon is an
escalation there was not even a pretense
in his trial that the prosecution of
steve bannon was lawful
so the constitution requires equal
protection heard that phrase that means
that selective prosecution is not
allowed it's unconstitutional if you
don't try one person for a crime you
don't get to charge another person for
the same crime
because that's selective it's political
but under merrick garland that's the new
rule offend us go to jail
at his trial steve bannon was not
permitted to say that his attorneys had
counseled him against bending the knee
the january 6 committee he couldn't even
say that nor was he allowed to argue
that his subpoena was legally invalid
why couldn't he argue that
all steve bannon was allowed to do was
shut up he had to remain silent and
await his conviction and that's what he
did
outside of federal court today steve
bannon pointed out that he subpoenaed
members of the january 6 committee to
testify at his trial
why can't you face your accusers isn't
that guaranteed under our system not in
this case
because having the january 6 committee
members show up
would expose them to the one thing they
cannot tolerate
which is cross-examination
so they refused watch
i want to thank the jury for the what
the effort they did the judge
particularly the court administration
here everybody i only have one
disappointment and that is the gutless
members of that show trial committee the
j6 committee didn't have the guts to
come down here and testify in open court
did you expect liz cheney and adam
kinzinger
to show up
they don't have to testify they don't
have to do anything they don't want to
do they can just send their enemies to
jail so their behavior is really not
that surprising because the january 6
committee itself does not allow
cross-examination
during its hearings you may have noticed
this it doesn't even allow the
identification of many witnesses they do
it anonymously
how do you define show trial that's how
you define show trial
so these are not hearings in any
recognizable sense
this is a show trial that is
exactly what it is that's not
overstatement
the committee did not allow the
cross-examination of former white house
aide cassidy hutchinson for example even
after she made claims that were insane
they made no sense she claimed that
donald trump tried to carjack his own
presidential limo and drive it to the
capitol
so if she'd been cross-examined which in
any hearing hearing
is permitted under the western system of
justice not the woke system of justice
that liz cheney has brought us but our
the conventional system that all of us
grew up with you would have a
cross-examination and someone might have
pointed out that the secret service
agents in that limo denied her account
but if you're watching on msnbc or cnn
which have taken this propaganda live
and then bragged about it
we're doing the bidding of the state
we're so proud we're calling it
journalism
we've refused to do that because we have
dignity and we're not liars unlike them
but if you're watching this on those
channels you would have no idea
that the secret service denied this
account
the secret service was never contacted
by liz cheney or adam kinser before the
testimony and that's bizarre
because if the committee wanted to get
to the truth of the trump grabbed the
wheel of the limo allegation they would
have talked to people who were there but
they didn't
republicans if they'd been allowed to
cross-examine if they demanded to
cross-examine we're not defending
republicans they've fallen down on the
job that's an understatement
but if someone had been allowed to ask
adult questions of the witness we might
have learned
what cnn viewers will never know and
that's that hutchinson reportedly tried
to get a job at mar-a-lago afterward
but none of that
was allowed
because it's pure propaganda it's been
going on for months now last night the
january 6 committee put on testimony
from an anonymous official can you
imagine an anonymous official
claiming that secret service agents
assigned to mike pence were using their
radios to tell their families goodbye
like they're on the deck of the titanic
because they assume they would die in
the capital because some guy in viking
horns on mushrooms was
spinning in round in circles and talking
about peace they were so afraid
watch this nonsense
the members of the vp detail at this
time were starting to fear for their own
lives
um there were a lot of there was a lot
of yelling um a lot of
a lot of very personal calls um over the
radio so
it was discerning i don't like talking
about it but um
that there were calls to
um say goodbye to family members it was
getting
for whatever the reason was on the
ground the bp details thought that this
was about to get very unclean
it's just absolutely shameful absolutely
shameful that the other channels played
this crap
without pushing back in even the mildest
way oh it's news it's not news and your
job in journalism is to hold the
powerful accountable it's not to do
their bidding or put their lies on tv
unedited in prime time which is what
every other channel has done except fox
news and we are proud of that well you
should be ashamed yeah you should be
ashamed
but there's no cross-examination allowed
in any of this because this committee
would not allow it no rebuttal of any
kind
so of course there was no inquiry as to
why a capitol hill police officer with a
documented history of recklessly
mishandling firearms shot an unarmed
woman in the neck an air force veteran
he shot her in the neck why
you're not allowed to ask
what happened to those thousands of
hours of surveillance footage why can't
we see those no you're not allowed even
to ask why we're not allowed to see them
we can't know why police are on video
letting people into the capitol complex
on january 6th
why is that
not allowed to ask
and this is going to continue as adam
kinzinger said this charade
which really does corrode the heart
of our system
this will continue
all the way till the midterms because as
kinsar was dumb enough to say the quiet
part out loud admitted this is a
political exercise watch
this investigation is not winding down
we may be towards the end of this
tranche of hearings we may have more
hearings in the future and the
investigation is still ongoing so we're
we're getting to the bottom of what we
need to know
yeah okay we're getting to the bottom
actually you're preventing legitimate
obvious questions from being asked and
just in point of fact no matter how long
these hearings go on they could go on
forever and adam kinzinger will still be
a sad tormented tiny man with a
miserable personal life so you know
that's some comfort
but the prosecutors here working for
kinzinger and cheney and the rest of
this committee just like the school
boards and the teachers unions last year
worked in tandem with the justice
department to punish the enemies of the
democratic party
what is that well it's the single
greatest threat to the rule of law in
the history of the united states that's
true
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight